you said that the world's first
trillionaire would be somebody in
climate change in the past
um let's update that what's uh today as
we stand here today what sector will the
world's first trillionaire come from
yeah I think it's energy transition
so energy so the things we've been
talking about yeah really so isn't it
okay well I think I think the way that I
think about so this is a single
individual sorry to interrupt you see
their ability to actually build a
company that makes huge amount of money
as opposed to this distributed idea that
you've been talking about yeah I'll give
you my philosophy on wealth
um
most of it is not you
um an enormous amount of it is
the genetic distribution of being born
in the right place and blah blah
irrespective of the boundary conditions
of how you were born or where you were
raised right so you know at the end of
the day you and I ended up in the United
States it's a huge benefit to us
second is the benefit of our age
it's much better and much more likely to
be successful as a 46 year old in 2023
than a 26 year old in 2023 because in my
case I have demographics working for me
with a 26 year old he or she has
demographics working slightly against
them can you explain that a little bit
what are the demographics here
in the case of me
the distribution of population in
America looks like a pyramid
and in that pyramid
I'm swedged in between these two massive
population cohorts the Boomers and then
these you know gen Z and millennials
um and that's a very advantageous
position it's not dissimilar to the
position that Buffett was where he was
you know packaged in between Boomers
beneath him and the silent generation
above him and being in between two
massive population cohorts turns out to
be extremely advantageous because when
the cohort above you transitions power
and capital and all of this stuff you're
the next person that likely gets handed
it so we have a disproportionate
likelihood to be you know we are lucky
to be older than younger
um so that's that's an advantage and
then the other advantage that has
nothing to do with me
is that I stumbled into technology I got
a degree in electrical engineering and I
ended up coming to Silicon Valley
and it turned out that in that moment it
was such a transformational Wind of
Change that was at my back
right so
the wealth that one creates is
a huge part of those variables and then
the last variable is your direct
contributions
in that moment and the reason why
that can create
extreme wealth
is because when those things come
together at the right
moment
it's like a chemical reaction I mean
it's just crazy so
that was sort of part number one of what
I wanted to say the second thing is when
you look then inside of these systems
where you have all these sit Tailwinds
right so in Tech I think I'd benefit
from these three big tail ones
if you build the company or are part of
a company or a part of a movement
your economic participation
tends to be a direct byproduct
of the actual value that that thing
creates in the world
and that the thing that that creates in
the world
will be bigger
if it is not just an economic system
but it's like a philosophical system
it changes the way that governance
happens it changes the way that people
think about all kinds of other things
about their lives
so there's a reason
I think why database companies are worth
acts social companies are worth why but
the military industrial complex is worth
you know as much
and I think there is a reason why that
if you for example were to go off and
build some newfangled source of energy
that's clean and Hyper abundant
and safe
that what you're really going to
displace
or reshape is trillions and trillions of
dollars of worldwide GDP so the global
GDP is I call it 85 trillion right it's
going at two to three percent a year
so in the next 10 years we'll be dealing
with a hundred trillion dollars of GDP
right somebody Who develops clean energy
in 2035
will probably shift
10 of that around
10 trillion dollars
a company can easily capture thirty
percent of a market three trillion
dollars
a human being can typically own a third
of one of these companies one trillion
dollars
so you can kind of get to this answer
where it's like it's going to happen in
our lifetime
but you have to I think find these
systems that are so gargantuan and they
exist today
it's more bounded because price
Discovery takes longer and an existing
thing it's more unbounded because you
know what it is you know the tentacles
that energy reaches
right of that 80 trillion dollars of
worldwide GDP I bet you if you added up
all the energy companies but then you
added up all of manufacturing
you know if you added up all of
Transport you'd probably get to like 60
of the 80.
do you have an idea of which energy
uh which alternate energy sustainable
energy
is the most promising well I think that
we
have to do a better job of exploring
what I call the suburbs of the periodic
table
so you know we're really good in Seattle
you know the upper Northwest yes you
know we're kind of good in Portland but
we're not existent in San Diego and we
have zero plan for North Carolina
through Florida
yeah and so is that a fancy way of
saying nuclear is should be part of the
discussion I think nuclear I think room
temperature semiconductors
I'm I'm not convinced right now that the
existing set of nuclear Solutions will
do a good job of scaling Beyond bench
scale I think there is a lot of
complicated technical problems that make
it work at a bench scale level even
partially but the energy equation
is going to be very difficult to
overcome in the absence of some leaps in
Material Science
have you seen any leaps is there
promising stuff like you're you're
seeing The Cutting Edge from a company
perspective yeah I would say not yet I
do but the precursor yes I have been
spending a fair amount of time so
talking about like a new framework
that's in my mind is around these room
temp superconductors
and so I've been kind of bumbling around
in that Forest
for about a year
I haven't really put together any
meaningful perspectives but again
talking about like trafficking in in
companies and Investments that are
very lonely but they allow me to
generate returns that are relatively
unique and independent that's an area
where I don't see anybody else when I'm
there I'll give you another area
you know we
um I think are about to unleash in a
world of zero energy and and zero
compute costs
computational biology will replace white
chemistry
and when you do that
you will be able to iterate On Tools
that will be able to solve a lot of
human disease
I think like if you look at the head
of like the top 400 most recurring rare
diseases
I think like half the number 200 is a
specific point mutation as just the
mismethylation between C and T
I mean that's like whoa wait you're
telling me in billions of lines of code
I forgot you know semicolon right there
that's causing this the whole thing to
miscompile so I just got to go in there
and boom and it's all done that's a
crazy idea that was a C plus plus c c
throwback for people that don't know
what I said there's two people who are
close
um but but um so that couldn't that be a
truly a source of uh the competition
biology unlocks I mean obviously
medicine is begging for the thing with
energy though is that the groundwork is
well laid
um
and talking about sort of like the upper
bound is well defined
the upper Bound in medicine is not well
defined because it is not
the sum total of the market cap of the
Pharma Industries it is actually the sum
total of the value of human life
and that's an extremely ethical and
moral question isn't there special
interests that are resisting uh
moving making progress on the energy
side so hot like uh governments and how
do you break through that I mean you
have to acknowledge the reality of that
I think it's less governance in fact
like I said I think President Biden has
done a really incredible job while Chuck
Schumer really is done a really
incredible job because
so just to give you the math on this
right like back to this so three percent
of everything is of a market or zealots
but when you get past five percent
things tend to just go nuclear to 50 60
percent
the way that they wrote this last bill
the cost I'll just use the cars as an
example the cost of an average car is 22
and a half thousand the cost of the
cheapest battery car is thirty thousand
and lo and behold there's a 7 500 credit
and it's like to think the Invisible
Hand didn't know that that math was
right I think is kind of a little bit
malarkey
and so the battery EV car is going to be
the same price as the thing and it's
going to go to 40 50 percent
um so we're already at this Tipping
Point so we're kind of ready to go
um in these other markets it's a little
bit more complicated because there's a
lot of infrastructure that needs to get
built so you know the the gene editing
thing as an example you know we have to
build a tool chain
that looks more like
um code that you can write to Facebook
is written in I think PHP originally HBO
which is I'm still a big fan of
sometimes you have to use the ugly
solution and make it look good versus
trying to come up with a good solution
um which will be too late